what is up
last weekend here at our house we are
moving again yes if this is news to you
please check out um some of our uh
previous uploads
um i think it's titled uh how we made a
million bucks but yes long story short
we were looking to start buying
different
homes in the area so we were gonna pull
from this
from the equity that we had
built in our home so when we got it
appraised we realized that we had
built about a million over the price
that we paid for this house
um
so it was just a perfect storm of us
going okay wait so if we sell our house
right now we're gonna make a million
bucks um
and
all we have to do is move out
yeah
we want to make a million bucks um so we
opted to sell our house we bought
another house that's currently being
built
um and it puts us in a really really
really great financial financial
situation because now we can start
buying up different properties uh in and
around
vegas just to set up you know more
assets more safety nets
it's just
asset building at this point so um god
damn i sound so old
but yeah that's the reason why we're
moving so
um
in the meantime though our house isn't
built just yet it's not gonna be
completed until october initially was
supposed to be supposed to be the
beginning of september but with a bunch
of supply chain change shortages and
stuff it's not going to be until october
um and you know when they tell you a
certain timeline you can't really count
on it too much because things can
rapidly change
so instead of us just kind of like
i don't know waiting around and
kind of being in limbo
we decided to get a short-term rental
which is kind of like an airbnb but it
is going to be an apartment
or a condo or something i don't know we
just signed the paperwork for it we
don't really care cause it's gonna be a
few months anyway we got it completely
furnished so think of like airbnb
um so all of our current furniture and
clothes and just a bunch of stuff that
we're not really using on a day to day
we're just going to leave it in pods
it's going to be parked in storage
and then
um
yeah packing has been kind of
interesting because as i'm packing i'm
throwing away stuff i don't need or i'm
giving away stuff you know that no
longer serves us or selling it or
whatever
and i'm also trying to think on a
day-to-day basis do we need these items
i have to set that aside so there's like
so many different piles
going on um
um so like this for example this is all
tiger clothes and i'm just like okay i
think i should just
keep this out because we got his pjs
t-shirts all that stuff and then if you
go in here
i have his school clothes
new backpack he starts next week so i'm
not gonna pack this obviously and then i
got some just like
i don't know more going out clothes if
you will
all of this though i think i can get rid
of it for three months the climate's not
gonna change too too much i do have a
couple jackets
laying on the bed already so all of this
stuff i will pack like this for example
i don't want it so that's gonna go away
but yeah we're pretty much
um i wanna say about like
85 90 packed now it's just all the
little stragglers right like all the big
items like i've cleaned out all the
closets as you can see
um took down our curtains
cleaned out everything that's in every
single cupboard
[Music]
the straggler part of it like that's
clothes that we wear on a daily so i'm
gonna keep that are like things like
this that i know type is not gonna use
or he's not gonna miss for like the next
three months
so all of these little stragglers are
the ones that
um i'm gonna have to take care of like
that can you guys hear bart's dad
that's his music either music or he's
watching the show or something but i
don't hear them talking
so i have no idea what he's watching
but
yeah
everything's getting packed
[Music]
and
while that's all happening i'm still
working
and tech is still on vacation so luckily
i have my mom here who's been my
lifesaver jesus christ it really does
take a village so she's been here so i
get to work a little bit
um
and i know i could hire like people to
pack and movers and all that stuff but
in my experience
unless you have a really good
relationship or a really good referral
um i've worked with two different
companies and both of those companies
the packing was horrendous and because
they don't know what room is gonna go
where or maybe they just weren't good
they started mixing up a bunch of room
items into one box and i'm like where's
this thing but it's labeled master but
this is for like garage like holy crap
so it took me months
literally months to find
stuff that i needed and then to finally
unpack which is funny because
a few months after now i'm packing it
all up anyway
you guys are already used to this [ __ ]
we're [ __ ] crazy people but
i hope to serve as an example of
anything is possible
so today is the weekend like i mentioned
earlier saturday to be exact
and um i did get a little bit work done
and i usually don't work on the weekends
but
i've just been packing look at my house
again that's the pile tech is going to
keep he's in his chinese
packing stuff
look at all this
label label label label label label
yeah
as you can see but yeah this is our
living room
or whatever this room was supposed to be
i think it was supposed to be a game
room
um
but now i'm going to spend some time
with my little monkey dude and my mama
and i feel like my mom's hiding because
she knows i'm vlogging
i feel like i should look for her ma
where are you
okay she's making her bed never mind
um i told tyka that i'm gonna make
something really fun with him today
monkey you have the thing
show me come here let's do it
so i saw this trend on tick tock
months back but now
we are finally gonna do it
what are we gonna do we're gonna open
this yeah what are we gonna do we're
gonna get grapes and then
a little lemon juice yep so we're gonna
get grapes
we need a bowl we're gonna make sour
candy grapes
yummy yummy for his belly everybody
okay so these are going to be our
ingredients some lemon juice
some starburst
yep pink powder
gelatin
some green grapes
and basically we're gonna dip one grape
into the lemon after the lemon we're
dipping it into the powder then we're
gonna put it in the plate then we're
gonna freeze it for an hour you got that
what about that you got that yeah okay
let's do it
you ready yep please okay play player
so
we don't have any toothpicks
[Music]
no all right let me get you a better
bowl
do you know where we're gonna open it
what
we can open it up for you see let me see
this line they have to open this
open it on there oh i see open here yep
you're right
i told him
okay so you have to be careful okay okay
i'll be careful
all right so let's put the powder here
you do it or i do it
how about we both both
we need a little bit oh my god smell
that
oh yeah
oh yum
it smells a little gross
it smells a little bit gross yeah i
don't think so
okay
one thing one thing at a time yeah i
don't want you to think i want you to
just
watch
and learn
player i think we have we can do that so
we already washed i'm gonna put it in
there yep we already washed our
be careful
yeah you're pretty jumping with your
teeth thanks dude
we already washed our grapes throw a
little one down squeeze it in there it's
hard
sure no but that's the boy
squeeze
wow that is pretty hard
okay i think that's enough yeah so i
think we can put it in there
so now you put it in there you're gonna
do
it in the lemon let's put the lemon
juice yep
and then drop it in there
no no no just the grape
can i rub my eye with this no baby
that's my mistake then i didn't explain
properly
that's mine okay okay so from the lemon
juice yeah you should we're both so
silly
just your mom okay so in the lemon juice
we're gonna pick that up and pick it up
no
no listen to me pick up the grape
put it in the powder and now we know i
would cover it
yep okay is it covered perfect so now
put it in there
just the grape not the powder just get
it just get it like this
and put it okay now another one
put it in there we're gonna do the same
lemon juice
okay
cover it in the lemon juice ready yeah
put it in there you put it in there
okay cover it up berry berry berry this
is a big scoop so okay now you pick it
up and put it in there oh yeah
there you go can i lick it go ahead
okay
here you go
go for it
i'll get two of the time no no just one
oh look this one's perfect okay
okay
cover it up that was good oh you want
the spoon
there you go next one and i'll put it in
there cover it up
oh good teamwork
okay make sure it's all covered okay
okay there you go that was perfect
perfect
there you go
good job
okay next one
nice
put it in there there you go
this is cool you like it
make sure the whole thing is covered
look that one's not covered the whole
way no no no no that's it too late
that's too late
okay that's it
shake it but make sure to shake it in
the bowl cake so that that doesn't
happen
go do it again
um
i'm sorry so i want you to do this look
if you go like this
right
and then you want to shake the excess so
you see how there's a lot of powder look
look
you see so you want to shake it off and
then you put it there okay
wow that's really good let me do this
one hey
how about we do
this you go
nice
perfect shake
powder's good huh
good job let me know when you need more
powder
whoa
landed in my face
okay
shake it beautiful
now we're getting the hang of it
that was a big one so we'll put it on
that yeah
okay
[Applause]
nice shake
wow
do we have any dabbing so we look at him
yep this is a good time to lick your
hands too oh it drops out it's okay yeah
because it's lipstick
i'll give you another one too thank you
very much welcome oh there's a lot of
sugar there
nice
nice
good job
look you can move the skin sorry you can
move it like this look look just go like
this
yeah like that and then you just pick it
like that so you don't have to cover it
can i show you another one
look let's go like this look and then
you just move the move it around like
that yeah you just roll it
and then you remove it and i haven't i
have a different one look and then here
just roll it hey mama i'll do it i'll do
it i'll do it
i'll do it i'll put it in there okay you
always do it no i don't here
you get one i have
[Laughter]
yeah without it being frozen
yeah
can i do one two wow
that's delicious oh oopsie okay that's
okay
yep
yummy huh
but
this is not healthy right
finished
product these are gonna go into the
freezer now and then you'll eat them
like gandhi
i'm gonna do it did you like it does it
taste good
okay
i'm up cycling one of our meal prep
boxes but that's where it is
the other way turn it the other way
hey google
one hour timer
all right one hour starting now
so now doing all sorts of laundry
and like i mentioned
i have to pack for three months but then
like for storage and then i have to pack
for
like living life so i've been able to
sort my clothes this is what's gonna get
packed away in storage
this is what's gonna get packed away in
storage
and then this is what i'll work with for
three months which i think is
more than enough clothing like that's a
lot of clothing the next round is
getting these boxes
putting down the ones i do not want to
bring or need
um and then
taping that up packaging it up so that
um when i do get the movers they can lug
them right out easy peasy
[Music]
we just had lunch taika
are you ready
they've been
frozen
you go first duty
they're gonna be cold okay they're
frozen
[Music]
you're going to love it
let's taste the sugar no no put the
whole thing in your mouth oh it's too
cold
i promise i promise it's not cold
yeah that one's a good one that was a
good one
what do you think what do you think
thumbs
we got a thumbs up
oh we got a medium oh we got a thumbs
down
okay today is day two of this vlog i had
to stop vlogging yesterday because
literally out of nowhere tyka got a
fever um we've been packing
since we got back to vegas which has
been for like a week and a half oh look
at him now he's good
i love you dude you're the best you're
the best
papa just got in from california just
right now yeah right now and he's
starving so i'm about to make him some
food but i just wanted to say yeah my
mom was like so my mom's worked with
kids for like i don't know 30 plus years
she's been a teacher and stuff works at
a school so she knows all the ins and
outs of kids and just all of that right
so she goes well sometimes kids do get
fevers when they're going through growth
spurts but from our current history any
time tyka has had a fever a few days
later he does get a seizure this is the
second time that
uh there were two times where he had a
fever days later he ended up getting
seizure now we know that he gets caesar
so caesar's wait
seizures
so he is on medication so i wasn't too
worried about it the only thing that
kind of got scary a little bit was he
takes the medicine 7 a.m 8 p.m
um and when i wanted to give him
children's tylenol because his fever was
at 102. i'm like holy crap can i cross
um can i can i give him both medications
because for me the seizure one
is super important for him to take it so
that he doesn't go through another
seizure but i needed his temperature to
go down so i'm like [ __ ] i had him naked
i was going to give him a bath but i
know that's or like a warm bath but i
know that's kind of nuts when you have
body aches and
shivers that i'm like [ __ ] i don't want
him to go through that and i knew baby
tyler and i was gonna and he was saying
he had a headache so i knew maybe
tylenol was gonna or children's head on
tylenol was gonna
uh
fix all that for him
so i'm like fox i had to call the
pharmacy
uh and asked them and they said it was
fine so ended up giving him both of that
stuff ended up sleeping with them
because he's been sleeping with my mom
in our guest room um ended up sleeping
with him because i know my mom is really
nervous because of the seizure we don't
know
anything about it yet we've never dealt
with it so i wanted to be there to
support her just in case he does go
through something
so we all slept together three in the
morning
he wakes up again with a fever giving
him another dose by three am he's up
awake ready to party so we all move the
party to the couch
and
at 3am we ended up watching toy story
and kind of going in and out of sleep so
if i look like this i know i normally
look like this but now i'm really tired
so i look even more like this shitty but
anyway about to cook papa some macro
friendly air fire recipe that i got from
this i don't know if he's a youtuber
first or instagrammer first but he's an
influencer i just came across his
account he's been online for several
years now he's not a baby account but uh
it's called um
flexible dieting lifestyle i think is
what what is
his uh page is called on
instagram if you're cutting uh and
tracking your macros i highly recommend
you checking out his recipes because the
video content is top tier the editing is
really good he is
his personality is really cool um but
his recipes
everything's from scratch um and they
just taste color so i'm gonna try to
attempt doing one for papa right now
it's like a breakfast burrito crunchwrap
type of
concoction um i'm still trying to
perfect the recipe so it might look like
[ __ ] but the macros are gonna be [ __ ]
banging
all right guys so i think i don't know
if i perfected it but i got a lot closer
to making it
like the account that i told you about
um it's currently
in the air fryer it has
seconds left
but let me show you this is what i was
gonna make this is what it needs to look
like and it's crunchy look at that
look at
that oh yeah so i'm making that for bart
let's see what happened
[Applause]
so here is my version of it just got out
of this out of the fryer
we'll see
moment of truth when papa gets to try it
all right papa we just got here from a
four-hour drive oh it's crispy oh yeah
it is from vegas i hope oh wait that's
what the knife's for yeah cut it open i
hope
i would cut it from the middle but up to
you whatever you want you know what this
is your world lily you keep telling me
what to do i'm so sorry i'm nervous i
just want it to be good
mmm smells really good
let's see i feel like i could have left
it in the airfryer a little bit longer
let's see show me this oh look at that
oh baby that made like a sandwich then
oh baby but it might fall apart because
the bottom has a hole but try it
wow what's that what's all that white
stuff egg white yep
egg whites
uh i wasn't as crunchy as i wanted it to
be
mmm
it's a little yummy is it no you promise
are you just saying that because you're
on camera no i promise oh i wish i would
have left it a little bit more i just
got scared i was gonna get burnt no it's
really good what is this tortilla yep
yes so out of ten what do we it's a ten
really yeah you're being nice i promise
it's yummy it's very good
we did it
so
i think we're about done
right like not wrapping but packing all
this stuff before with my hands before
the movers actually come and pick
everything up
it's
awesome i gotta show you the garage so
keep in mind
things look really freaking sloppy
because i mean there's just crap
everywhere but
it makes sense it's like this chaos
excuse me
so i'm very proud of myself because i
like order
i like cleanliness
so i kind of like organized it for them
to just come
and
pick everything up
kind of laid it out like this like
anything like this
they'll put it in a box
and put it away themselves
so i tried to do all the heavy lifting
putting stuff away for them because they
can do it but i just rather do it myself
but these are all the things i'm gonna
like donate to my mama
and then we do have professional
gym
installers and uninstallers so they'll
be also coming the same day we're going
to paint all of this white again restore
it
and um
see
yeah everything's pretty much done
like this is just
like
personal stuff that i'm gonna take
when we move
pantry i condensed everything
i have a [ __ ] ton of food but because
we're dieting
like we kind of just kind of have to do
it because we got home so much
but yeah
we're like so done
and it's
kind of cool having this guy back
because
he's been helping a lot look at how good
he's looking
[Music]
okay well fine we're done
on that note you guys i'm gonna go wash
my hands college day
i've been dealing with a sick baby
packing
and just trying to survive you know what
i mean thank you guys so much for
watching we'll see you tomorrow